White House National Security Advisor
John Bolton 'is shifting president
Trump's plan to quickly withdraw
American troops from Syria Bolton who's
travelling in Israel said yesterday that
the 2,000 troops will not leave Syria
until Isis is defeated and Turkey
guarantees the safety of America's
Kurdish allies he said there's no
timetable for withdrawal last month the
president said it was time for US troops
to come home claiming Isis was defeated
David Martin is at the Pentagon David
good morning good morning president
Trump's plan to immediately withdraw US
troops from Syria was criticized by both
allies and members of his own party and
it triggered the resignation of his
defense secretary James Madison but now
National Security Advisor John Bolton
says the US will not leave Syria until
it accomplishes its mission including
destroying Isis to the point that it
cannot make a comeback the Pentagon says
the US and its allies continue to
conduct air and artillery strikes
against Isis targets in Syria Bolton is
also seeking guarantees from Turkey that
it will not attack Kurdish fighters who
have been allies with the u.s. turkey
considers some Syrian Kurds to be
members of a terrorist group and has
been massing troops on the border to go
after them Bolton is expected to discuss
discuss that issue with Turkish
president air Dewan when they meet in
Agoura tomorrow defense officials were
initially told to have all US troops out
of Syria by the middle of this month but
president Trump acknowledged yesterday
it will take longer and won't happen
quote until Isis is done Gayle thank you
very much David